- How many people, in their lifetimes,
do a job that they love doing?
Maybe I have ADD,
but I want to be able to do everything.
Why can't we do everything?
People have to like you or relate to you
for who you are.
You can't be someone else at least.
- Hello, Believe Nation!
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to
solve all of the major
problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to
learn from one of India's
highest paid and most popular
actresses Priyanka Chopra,
and my take on her top ten
rules for success, volume two.
Rule number two is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always, guys, as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
And when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick for yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(uplifting music playing)
- But, see what is the choice?
That you walk a path like everyone else,
dressed in suits, go to work,
and come back, and never have a legacy,
or you swim upstream
like a trout against norm
and then whatever little
you achieve is only yours?
It's not like everyone else.
And I'd rather have something
that is my path, paved by me,
something that is my legacy,
my own self, my own achievement.
than being one of the many
successful people in the world.
I just love what I do,
and I'm good at it.
And I love the ability
to wake up in the morning and say,
"Oh my God, I get to go to work."
I mean, how many people,
in their lifetimes,
do a job that they love doing?
Most people do it for survival.
Sure, we need to feed our families,
we need to survive,
it's our career,
we have to do it.
But to wake up with
my feet and my fingers tingling
and say, "Wow, I have this to do.
"I have that to do today."
And it's an amazing feeling,
and I don't take it for granted.
I'm a storyteller.
And I'm not someone who
restricts myself to one thing.
Ever.
I've never been that person.
Maybe I have ADD,
but I want to be able to do everything.
Why can't we do everything?
- Sure.
- And especially women,
we're great at multitasking.
So I want to produce,
I want to have a business,
I'm producing here,
I'm going to produce in India,
Hindi films, regional films.
I want to be able to
act in them, maybe not.
You know, there's so many
things that I can do,
which I want to be able to explore.
I'm a little, I don't
know how to say this.
I have, people call it arrogance,
I call it self-assurance.
But I am who I am.
If you like it, great.
If you don't like it, I don't care.
(laughing)
That's who I've always been.
So, whether I'm coming to America,
whether I go to India,
I'm always true to just who I am.
If you try and change
yourself according to,
thinking, "Oh I'm going
to a different country."
Or, you know, "I need to please,
"or I need to not be alien enough."
You're over-thinking it.
People have to like you
or relate to you for who you are.
You can't be someone else at least.
So I've stayed very true to who I am.
Whether it's in India or here,
I mean, as much as I can, of course.
You have to be open to understand
and accept the fact that
you won't know everything.
And people won't know
everything about you.
So it's an education.
I'm enjoying so much,
educating my cast my crew
and the people that I meet about India
and achard and biryani and diwali,
I'm as daisy as it gets,
and they have so much fun
getting to know India through me,
and me the same way.
You have to accept your uniqueness.
When my publicist, I remember,
emailed me and he says,
"You're being considered."
Because the voting and stuff was going on
in the 100 most influential people.
I was like, "Wow!"
That in itself was the achievement for me.
That I'm in consideration
with this lot of people.
Then to be a part of the list,
then to be on the cover of the magazine,
not just in Asia, but in the US as well.
And then to have my
palmistry within 10 days.
- That's right, palmistry Priyanka Chopra.
- Yeah, that one week was
a real big pinch me moment.
- Tell me.
There's all this stuff, right?
There is, of course, the sweat,
you talked about your tears,
about flying here for a weekend,
but what is the sacrifice
you make to achieve this?
- Sacrifice your life.
- Really?
- Yeah, your life is your work completely.
I get to meet my friends in Bombay
only for the 20 days that
I might come here now,
for this year, at least.
My family, yes I can fly them down.
To be in a completely new country.
Get to know new people.
Reintroduce yourself and see if
these are friends for life or not.
It's not just the fact
that that's all I do,
but it's such a solitary thing to do.
I'm willing to sacrifice my sleep,
I'm willing to sacrifice food,
I'm willing to sacrifice quality of life,
if that's what you want to call it.
And to be an achiever because
to be an achiever you have
to let go of some things.
I make it a point, that I
fly my family wherever I am.
I fly my friends wherever I am.
I fly my cook wherever I am
because I need my dal chawal at night.
It's very important.
But besides that, I think,
you know, when you want global domination,
you have to pay the price for it.
I like pushing the envelope.
I like pushing myself.
Actually, it's a very selfish thing.
I have a very short attention span.
I get bored if I have to do the same thing
or if something doesn't challenge me.
I'm in a profession where
I can push myself so much,
and I live with adrenaline of working best
under pressure somehow.
And I'm very fortunate that I get roles
that are written for me,
which give me the ability to do that.
So, why not?
- Do you have any advice
that you can give entrepreneurs
or people who are trying to
break out of their comfort zone?
- Well, it is scary.
I will always say that, you know.
Especially business because it's
a very scary place to be and it changes,
it has so many ups and downs.
But a very very dear friend of mine,
and a mentor, Jimmy Iovine,
who created Beats by Dre,
he works for Apple Music.
He told me this one piece of advice,
which I tied a knot and I kept.
He said to be successful,
you have to be able to
walk away from a deal.
You have to.
If you want it bad enough,
then people are going to give it to you
at pittance, you know?
But you have to be able
to walk away from a deal.
That's when you become stronger.
And you have more confidence in yourself,
so that's how I've started living my life.
And I guess that's the advice
I would give all young entrepreneurs.
- Do you think about the next act?
Do you think about,
I know it sounds too early to ask,
but do you think about where you will be
five years later?
- I mean, hopefully, I
will still be working.
As what, where, how, I've never known.
I'm not someone who plans my career.
I'm very instinctive.
If I like something, I do it.
Hence, the reason I fail a lot also.
Because, you know, I take risks.
I take chances.
It's very easy to have a safe career.
But I want to be able to
have a path which is mine,
yeah, I screw up sometimes, but it's mine.
No one else did it before me.
It's completely empty
territory till I get there.
It's my footprints.
I take a lot of pride in that.
So, I don't know where it'll be,
but it'll be different, I can assure you.
It'll be a precedent.
I like setting precedents.
- You'll be breaking new ground.
- Yeah, I want to do things
that people are like,
"Oh, she's doing that now?"
I look for things like that.
Whether it's acting, producing,
I don't know what it'll be.
I don't know.
I was very fascinated with show-business
when I joined the movies.
And I found so many sad stories
of people who after
they've become superstars,
or they realize that they're superstars,
you know, the downfall.
It's going to happen to everyone.
Everyone.
I knew that before I
started my first film.
So I'm not afraid of it.
I just know that I'll have
a plan B when that happens.
Creativity can be morphed
into so many things.
Today I write, I sing, I write columns,
I've written for Elle, New York Times,
and the Star Times.
I act in movies.
I'm producing films.
There is a gazillion things
you can do as a creative person.
So I'm prepared for that.
So, yeah, I do believe you can't ever
sit down on your hands and say,
"Alright, now I'm a star."
- But you wanted to challenge
me to wing-eating contest.
- Yeah, see I am...
- This is insane.
No one challenges me on my show.
I'm the good luck charm.
You want to do this?
- I think we should.
You know what, guys, we're in New York.
- Let's do it!
Come on!
(audience cheering)
(music playing)
- Oh snap.
- Oh look at this.
Here we go.
Alright, these already look hot.
These in front of us
are from Atomic Wings,
here in New York.
They're made with their nuclear hot sauce.
- And I have Tabasco just
in case that's not enough.
And I have milk just
in case it's too much.
(audience laughing)
- I'm not going to need the milk.
- I might.
- Yeah, whoever eats the most
wings within 20 seconds wins.
- Hoo, damn.
- Yeah.
Let's get 20 seconds on the clock.
- Yeah, okay.
- Ready?
On your mark, get set, go!
(fast music playing)
(audience cheering)
I can't do more than one.
I can't do it.
I can't do more than one, come on.
(audience cheering)
I couldn't even do one.
I got a big chunky one.
My first wing was a big wing--
- Oh, excuses.
- Oh excuses.
Who doesn't love this person right here?
Priyanka Chopra.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
If you want to get your pick
of who I should profile
next in the top tens,
check out the link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also wanted to give a
quick shout out to Russel Duvall.
Russel, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word.
I really appreciate the support, man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And, whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- Success is not a destination.
People always think that,
"Oh my God, this person's so successful."
Because they had a successful movie
or successful show,
but success is a journey.
You have to consistently
always always be successful,
that's when you're really successful
because otherwise you'll be remembered
for your last failure.
And I've had a few, but
I just have to compensate
for my failure by just
getting up and running.
The more time you take
to, sort of, mourn it,
you're wasting that much more
time in being successful.
So, you just have to, you know, perk up.
Pick yourself up, dust yourself off,
and just say, "Alright, what can I do? "
There's always a solution.
People always get mistaken
that because this year
has been what it has been,
it's been because I consistently
worked for about 10 years.
So now, I know my job enough to be
able to be appreciated for it.
But if I hadn't had the last 10 years,
I would never have had this year
or the year before that.
So success is not a destination
where you are power.
It's not like, okay today you're powerful.
You have to consistently be powerful
and consistently be successful.
And that is a journey.
It'll never be a step.
- I'm really confused,
where is the switch on, switch off button?
Priyanka, you come from America
to do a Kashibai so convincingly.
- Yeah, that whole last scene
where he calls me mustani,
I came down for a weekend to shoot it.
I shot it over Saturday Sunday.
And it was a hectic trip.
But I think that's my job.
My process is very different.
Nobody taught me what acting was about.
My acting school has been my career.
My gurus have been my
filmmakers and my co-actors.
So, I think I learned my own process,
which is, I create a personality.
I'm not someone who
needs to stay in the mood
or I don't go into a character.
I create the person.
Like I create Kashi.
I think about what she likes,
how she behaves, you know,
what her choices are,
what her favorite food is.
You can ask me anything about a
character and I know them.
They become like my best friends
or my sisters.
And after that, I don't
need to stay in the mood
because I know them so well,
you can throw any scene at me,
and I'll be able to do it.
So my process is very different,
because of which, I can
switch on and off really well.
I was different.
I still am different.
I'm in a country which is
very far far away from home.
Very far away from familiarity.
And I think that's what my strengths are.
When I was young, I
didn't understand that.
When I was a kid in school,
when I was being bullied,
when I didn't understand
who I was turning into.
But what makes you different,
if you identify that,
and you realize that, alright,
this is what's different about me.
If you think about it that's
exactly what makes you special.
That's exactly what makes you unique.
And you need to just,
and I did that over time,
be the best version of yourself
cause the more different you are,
the more special you are.